un tel honneur d'être ici assis avec l'
un des plus grands scénaristes d'Hollywood que
vous entendez exagérer juste
un peu alistair mendier n'est peut-être pas ce
qu'il allait payer pour ça ouais ouais
je vais bien ouais c'est ce que vous dites toujours
mais son dernier thriller dont il parle
avoir une vie propre
deux femmes ont été assassinées ces
derniers jours et elles ont toutes les deux des liens
avec vous une imagination très active
sur pourquoi Pallister tu es l'homme le plus
paranoïaque que j'ai jamais rencontré quelle est ta
nouvelle théorie quelqu'un essaie de me piéger
il n'y a pas de capitaine McCarthy mais je
lui ai parlé hier soir le fou fou est-ce que c'est
personnel amusant ce que je fais quelque chose
va arriver  si vous êtes en danger mr.
Bain
robert moi euh non mes affaires jusqu'à ce que la
paranoïa puisse t'éviter beaucoup d'
ennuis Billy Zane je ne sais pas quels
problèmes tu as dans ta vie martin
landau quelque chose pue exactement donne moi
M. Sanders prend une douche Michael Rooker
si tu t'en rends compte  ou pas tu es dans
cette merde jusqu'au cou mon
ami et Danny Glover aucune de ces
bases faites attention à ce que vous écrivez
obtenez du sang sur vos mains
mr.  haricot êtes-vous à l'intérieur de mr.  Bain sors
dehors s'il te plait mysteria comment ça se termine
je t'aimerais
toi